hello and welcome to a week 14 edition
of the fantasy football show here at
Bleacher Report presented by State Farm
my name is Adam Levan establish the
run.com as always joined by Michael
Leone who is oddly wearing a Minnesota
Vikings Randy Moss Jersey I believe that
is tonight even though Randy Moss one of
the greatest offensive players of all
time and we're preparing tonight for
what we expect to be one of the ugliest
NFL games of all time Michael how do you
explain
Randy Moss Jersey here today listen we
get Justin Jefferson back this week so I
figured it was a little bit fitting go
with a Vikings wide receiver in honor of
Justin Jefferson's return all right on
today's show we know everybody is
getting ready for their fantasy playoffs
two teams on a buy this week also a
really bad injury week in week 13 so we
know that you might have some Thin start
sit decisions we're going to talk about
eight guys who we think are pretty good
starts even though you might be thinking
about sitting them or on the fence
before we get into that while people get
in here take a couple questions from
chat 4 PF jeansy says Josh DS or jacobe
Meyers you know Leon I I was cons I was
really optimistic on Josh DS last week I
thought it was a really good spot for
Josh DS I did not expect them to throw
to so many different guys in the game it
has been so Consolidated in IND but
between Pitman and downs in this game
they showed up with a bunch of Alec
Pierce targets and a bunch of tight end
targets I don't know how sticky that's
going to be I still like downs but what
do you think about Downs
verse uh uh the other one I forgot
already um I think I think I think you
got to stick with Downs it was a little
bit out of character for them to spread
it around as much as they did I think
down should be more involved you're
coming out of the bye he had a 32%
Target share in week 12 that obviously
dipped to 12% we've also seen them throw
a little bit more aggressively recently
which is nice to see and maybe continues
with Jonathan tayor out so I'm still
buying Downs I like this offense a bit
better than what's going on with Vegas
where you just don't have stable
quarterback play and you've got a pretty
run heavy approach and facing a solid
defense
overall next question is from Free Hug
says DeAndre Swift or Alvin CRA so to me
this is an easyish one I
mean DeAndre Swift loses every goal line
carry to the tush push everyone if the
Eagles are with inside the two yard line
they're going to the tush push it is
hard
to um get your head around how much that
hurts a DeAndre Swift projection when
you don't get the goal line carries
meanwhile chimra with Michael Thomas and
rased Shah out I know the tesm stuff is
annoying but you saw the ceiling that
tesm can have last week very few running
backs can catch six balls in a game and
also score two rushing touchdowns so it
would be chimra over Swift here for me
this week Le would you agree there yeah
I would agree with Cima Kevin fricky 23
asks Breece hall or Ezekiel Elliott Adam
we're down bad that this is a legitimate
start sit question here in week 14 uh we
were pretty big Breeze Hall stands over
at ETR has not broken well with the
quarterback play for the Jets and now
he's a bit banged up I think he's had
two dmps to start the week so we got to
keep an eye on that I'm still you know
tempted to just play the more talented
explosive player which is clearly Bree
Hall so if Hall suits up I'd lean that
way but you got to make that decision
tonight uh with Zeke going tonight and I
do expect Zeke even though I don't
things will go well for the Patriots
offense for Zeke from an efficiency
standpoint they're just going to run a
ton and with mandre out it's going to be
you know mostly Zeke back there uh Bree
said today that he's going to play on
Sunday um for what it's whatever it's
worth he said he's going to play and by
the way I do think Breece would have had
a huge year if Aaron Rogers had stayed
healthy like huge Garrett Wilson and
Bree Hall would have had huge years if
Aaron Rogers stayed healthy just was not
meant to be all right let's get into
this week's featured segment which is
eight must starts to get you into the
fantasy playoffs we'll start with Drake
London so I I understand that in game a
lot of games the Falcons only want to
drop back 20 25 times at most in home
games they've dropped back more stats
have been better I don't think Drake
London is competing as much with Kyle
pittz now as maybe we thought that he
would and so in a really good matchup
against the Bucks I mean this second has
been getting flamed all year if Atlanta
Gets behind at all or maybe even if they
don't I like this spot for Drake London
I know it's been a struggle Leone any
thoughts on where London is at right now
and then we can move to our second guy
yeah it's also a dome game on a week
where we have a lot of low totals and a
lot of potential weather problem so I
think that's for him I will note that
Atlanta has particularly established it
the last three weeks passed right over
expectations of minus 17 % minus 16% and
minus 22% their three lowest of the
season but as you noted against Tampa
Bay they are one of the defenses teams
throw against most frequently our second
must start to get to the Fantasy Playoff
Zach moss and not a great result for
Moss last week being the starter in the
absence of Jonathan Tor but the role
Adam was really really strong for him
I'm taking a look at our expected points
model and even though Moss only scored I
think like 7.7 PPR points his role
indicated he should have scored more
like 18 which was top 10 on the week one
of the best roles so I think you got to
go right back to him in this spot I mean
Zach Moss had seven carries seven from
inside the 10 yard line did not score a
touchdown on any of them he had 19 out
of 19 running back carries in the game
you could not find better running back
usage than
what Zach Moss had now he get to face
the Bengals assuming Jonathan Taylor is
out I'm going right back to Zack
Moss third must oh you know what let's
go back to chat for a second here ecty
goat says James Connor or Raheem moer so
this new Cardinals coaching staff has
used James Connor a little bit
differently when they fall behind if
they're in clear passing situations it's
not as much James Connor but you saw
what he can can do when they win games
they won in Pittsburgh last week by two
touchdowns and James Conor had 24
carries I mean he can have some huge
usage games when they play
well of
course Cardinals are on a buy this week
so I'm not sure yeah another trick
question chat chat tries to sneak these
in on us we had one ago with Atlanta on
by uh but yeah moster still I mean the
efficiency upside for Miami week in and
week out is pretty strong even with hn
coming back I think there's just routes
especially in close games for moster to
get there I don't think it's going to be
particularly close against Tennessee but
moster should you know he only needs 10
to 15 touches to really make a big play
Josh tederer asks Rashi rice or kelvin
Ridley this
week man I think with Lawrence likely
out here and Jacksonville on the road
possibly bad weather against one of the
best defenses in the entire league I'd
actually go Rashi rice you know I don't
want to overthink the talent here
because typically you would definitely
go Ridley over rice in this spot but
contextually I think all the tiebreakers
favor rice so I'll go with him yeah this
Chiefs Bills game could be a really
high-scoring game I mean I know Chiefs
defense has played well but Bill's
defense has been struggling so badly and
Josh Allen has been doing the Superman
thing for much of the year so yeah it
would be Rashid rice for me there P
Wheels says Josh Kelly or Damen Pierce
in full PPR these like Josh Kelly
reports that are out there I mean people
are running with it shefer tweeted about
it I
mean the report from Brandon Staley is
we need to get Josh Kelly more carries
and and Austin Eckler I get what he's
saying Austin Eckler has been struggling
down to 2.9 yards per carry since he got
hurt with that high ankle spring in week
one I'm just not sure Josh Kelly is the
answer to any of the Chargers problems
so I'm a bit skeptical on the report but
it's not like Damen Pierce is a great
play either so what do you think about
Kelly versus Pierce here I think I'd go
Pierce I'm expecting him to have more of
the goal line rooll than Devon single
ter also this spot against the Jets
could just be right for a ton of rushing
attempts where this split workload might
not be as much of a detriment as it
normally would because I think both
backs could get into the double digits
and Carries here in this spot against
the
Jets all right one more chat question
here Jobe Myers who we already talked
about or Romeo dos this week at Flex you
know what you know what Leon let's not
even answer this question let's just
transition like a true television
professional to the must starts for the
playoffs because our number three must
start is indeed Romeo dos and this
assumes that Christian Watson is going
to be out so Christian Watson pulled his
hamstring for the fifth time in in three
years last week I mean come on man we
got to stretch you know we got to
stretch we got to be out there
stretching the hammies all the time I
had a stretch lab appointment today
exactly exactly and so if he's out and I
do think he'll be out you move Romeo
dobs to the number one receiver spot
against a very beatable Giants defense
quietly quietly Jordan love has been
playing at a really Elite level the
quarterback position for the Packers so
yeah it'll be dos there for me assuming
Christian Watson
is out Leone go ahead to our next must
start next me next must start is Austin
Eckler and you hit on it with Kelly like
you know this daily coach talk I think
might be a little bit motivational or it
might swing a carrier too but I don't
think Eckler is gonna flat out lose his
role and I know he's been pretty dusty
he hasn't been fully healthy he's kind
of on the wrong side of the age Cliff
where we like to see running backs but
with all that said much win spot for the
Chargers against Denver it's one of the
higher totals of the week both defenses
aren't very good I think there's a lot
of ways Eckler can get there even if he
isn't efficient on the ground I think
you know his touchdown upside is always
really strong the way they use him by
the goal line and he can just rack up a
lot of PPR points on short a do
catches all right let's get back to chat
we of course love the chat Harper 6 says
T Higgins or javante Williams in his
Flex so T Higgins came back in that game
that crazy game on Monday night against
the Jaguars I thought he looked pretty
healthy but it was clear that Jake
Browning had eyes for Jamar Chase and
and rightfully so Jake Browning does not
have much arm strength reminds me of
Colt McCoy a little bit like popgun arm
but can get it to Jamar Chase in kind of
these short areas I don't know if it
fits as well with t Higgins that said
there's going to be a lot of Target
share variance I think Tan's a good
enough player to earn more targets any
thoughts on T versus javante here Leone
I like javante again I like this game
environment and on the by Leone model
over at established your run looking at
underperforming running backs who should
do better as long as their workload
isn't cut and we don't think javon's
workload is going to get cut javante is
one of five names on the list he's
averaged 9.1 PPR points per game his
last three our model puts him more like
12.4 our DFS projections have him even
higher than that so I know it hasn't run
well for javante but he's going to find
the end zone sooner or later get him in
your lineup yeah I I'm concerned that
javon's like explosiveness has been
sapped a bit by the knee injury he has
zero runs or I think one run over 18
yards all year but yeah um I would go
with him too Doug Ren Says Z Jones Adam
thielen or Chris Godwin so Z Jones I
think it's a big Boost from Christian
Kirk being out I was really sad
Christian Kirk went out uh he was having
a great year he was one of our favorite
players to draft before the season where
he was being drafted Z Jones to me gets
the biggest boost there Godwin there's a
lot of Coach speak around Godwin guy had
zero catches last week I mean he's just
getting absolutely iced by Mike Evans
which is something I did not think would
happen in a million years that Mike
Evans would be so far ahead of Chris
Godwin in every category so is an
interesting one thelen's also kind of
falling off a cliff a bit here Leone Z
Thelen or Godwin
I think it's Steen or Godwin taking the
guys that are safer PPR producers I
think Godwin should do a little bit
better this week I know he was on the
injury report last week had some neck
thing don't want to like overly blame
that because it didn't sound too super
serious but you never know if that
impacted things ultimately the boring
answer here is probably gonna be Thelen
um just High catch rate high Target
share think he has the best floor of the
bunch and you're not really excited
about the ceilings of any of these three
anyways yeah and this game is indeed in
Dome here for Thelen they'll be down in
the Super Dome all right let's jump into
the fantasy bundles presented by State
Farm where bundling your home in auto
insurance is just another way to save
with the personal price plan all right
for you guys who are not familiar
bundles simply means teammates that we
think work well together for this week
if anyone plays DFS or wants to try DFS
it's kind of our specialty at ETR and
stacking is something you're going to
want to do in tournaments the first
stack we have to talk about I mean it's
the same thing every week Tua to Tyreek
absolutely cannot be ignored at this
point I think one interesting note is
that before the year Tyreek said he
wanted to get over 2,000 yards this
Dolphins coaching staff I think wants to
get him over 2,000 yards he's on Pace
for 2083 right now I think they'll
continue to feed him and feed him in a
big way not only because he wants to get
2,000 yards but also obviously he's one
of the most valuable players in the
entire NFL and has been absolutely
dominant so an absolute no-brainer every
week but certainly this week against the
Titans who are a bit of a pass funnel
Tua to
Tyreek y only go ahead with our second
bundle yeah second one is gonna be Dak
Prescott to Jake Ferguson and you know
not to be repetitive but Dallas since
the by week is really slinging in it
putting the ball in dax's hands they've
been consistently positive pass rad over
expectation game in and game out and
dax's performing at a super high level
since week eight that stretch does
include a game against Philly in which
Dallas threw 44 times and really you
know some of the pass numbers for Dallas
as high as they are they're muted by the
team winning some really big games here
but against Philly Philly's offense
should be able to push Dallas and Philly
is one of those teams that has a strong
run defense so teams typically are
attacking them through the air to begin
with so the combination of volume
efficiency ceiling is outrageous for for
Dak and Company and Ferguson has looked
really strong lately one of the most
consistent higher upside tight end
performers out there right now everybody
has a pass heavy game plan against the
Eagles and I think like where eagles
have it invested the least historically
is that linebacker um where Jake
Ferguson operates a lot third bundle
Gardner
Inu m Michael Pitman I'm not sure people
are aware Michael Pitman has at least
eight catches in nine of 12 games this
year I
mean that is tough to do now he gets one
of the best possible matchups this
Bengals team man I understand
everybody's excited about Jake Browning
their defense is getting shredded on a
week to week basis so really good spot
for the Colts really good spot for
Michael Pitman Gardner mro is someone
that you can play cheaply in DFS stuff I
think is an interesting play this week
against the Bengals obviously Pitman is
really really strong we already talked
about the down stuff as
well the only fourth
bundle I'll go with Justin fields to DJ
Moore track in this game but it seems to
have cleared a little bit and this
Detroit defense has really struggled the
last several they gave up 28 points to
the Saints 29 Points to the Packers 26
points to this Bears team 38 point
points to the Chargers those are their
last four games and the defense has
really fallen off I think Chicago is
going to throw the ball more than they
did the last time these two teams fa the
pass rate over expectation for Chicago
was pretty high last week with Fields
getting healthier and the target sharing
efficiency for DJ Moore has been really
strong all season long Fifth and final
bundle is going to be one that's been
hitting a lot this year and like Mike
Evans at age 30 with Baker I didn't
think this was possible but we have to
stop being stubborn he has been one of
if not you know easily top six top seven
wide receiver in the NFL this year not
even close now he gets an Atlanta team
which may be without top cornerback AJ
Terrell so another really good spot here
for Mr Mike
Evans those are our bundles for the week
Tu a Tyreek Dak Ferguson minu picket
Fields DJ Moore Baker Mike
Evans let's get back to some chats uh
chat questions here let's not uh ask
about any guys that are on buys here
chat let's let's get it together a
little bit all right uh question from C
flakes is George Pickins a must start I
it would depend what else you have but I
don't have a great feeling about George
pickings tonight there has been some
pretty drastic splits for Mitchell
trabis who's starting tonight that he
favors Deontay Johnson a little bit more
I don't think that's sticky or matters
that much but it's just worth something
noting George pins simply has not earned
targets before M can left after mcna
left whatever I would not consider a
must start but I don't know who else you
have so yeah that's a tough one to
answer for the chips says Devon Anan or
Jamar Chase for his Flex spot oh here we
go with the humble brags yeah this is
the first one of the week two of the
best uh fantasy Assets in the league I
would say Devon hen and Jamar chase the
only thing I'll say about hen is that he
did not play a ton in the first half
last week it was once the game got out
of hand that he really started to go
nuts hn only five opportunities in the
first half of that game last week but I
definitely think they could ramp him up
more here against the Titans what do you
think about hn vers
Chase I think I'd go chase here but
really unless this is a shallow League
you you should be finding a way to start
both these guys I mean Chase is one of
the best fantasy wide receiver assets
out there and Anan not to be like too
simple-minded about it but every time
he's played and you know not left the
game early he scored like 20 25 plus
fantasy points with some even higher
performances it's absolutely outrageous
and there's part of me that just says
like just play him until you know we see
the results not go that way I know he's
run a bit fortunate whether it's
efficiency or blowout but it keeps
happening for him so I would I would
chase the heater with
hn all right Seahawks fan says DK meaf
or puka niua Seahawks fan is asking if
you should bench DK meaf so pukan nakua
took a scary hit he's taking a ton of
hits this year man seems like he's
always over the middle he's always
getting banged up U but he's playing
through it and is certainly playing well
DK metf had an outrageous game against
the Cowboys when we last saw him Leone
any thoughts on meaf vers
puka it's really close I think right now
I'd be leaning towards metf this is one
of the games La at Baltimore that we're
most concerned about potential weather
we've got only a 40 point total there I
know at least earlier in the week
Stafford's over under pass yards was
like 200 which takes into account that
weather so you know I know Adam a lot of
times you think the weather's overblown
and maybe come Sunday morning we won't
care but as a tiebreaker um mat CF
coming off that huge game in Seattle
likely having to throw a whole bunch
against San Francisco I know San Fran
could dominate them and could go bad for
the whole offense but I feel a little
bit more comfortable with metf right now
I think it's metf pretty clearly strikes
me as healthier strikes me as
uh probably better quarterback play and
like this San Francisco matchup they
have gotten uh burned up a little bit by
Alpha wide receivers Ford the chips says
Jaylen Herz or CJ strad for my QB for my
qb1 so my concern on stad is that tank
Dell meant a lot to this entire offense
he was incredible tankel was going to
miss the rest of the year with a broken
leg after the Texans foolishly put him
in the scrum to block on a QB sneak so I
think it's hurts pretty easily here but
yeah any thoughts on strad versus Herz
Leon Herz is almost always our answer in
any One V one I mean his rushing upside
with the push tush is insane it's an
insulated offense but aside from him
always being number one I agree it's not
a great spot for Stroud ignoring even
the Dell stuff at the Jets you go from a
dome to an outdoor environment weather
components you face an offense that
stinks which encourages Houston to run
the ball and you face a defense that is
pretty good it's just not a good spot
contextually for
strad all right let's get back into our
borderline starts our our sneaky starts
for getting into the fantasy
playoffs number five is going to be
Brandon Cooks
I mean this Dallas Team all they want to
do is pass now and all the eagles want
to do is give it up through the air and
Brandon Cooks has separated massively
from Michael Gallup it's just awesome
spot for Brandon Cooks Dak Prescott Jake
Ferguson CD lamb awesome spot for them
really excited for this game I believe
that's yeah that's the night game on
Sunday night clear the calendar Eagles
Cowboys Sunday night Leon you can keep
it moving here yeah let's go TM Hill for
number six uh starting him at tight end
is looking really really good with how
bad the tight end play has been overall
for fantasy and if you look at Hill's
role he surprisingly caught multiple
passes in six to seven games that gives
us a little bit more floor more
importantly though with all the
receivers and whatnot out for New
Orleans they're going to him on the
ground it makes sense quarterback plays
struggling he had a season High 13
carries last game he's always one of the
biggest touchdown threats because the
way they utilize him by the goal line
and it couldn't come really in a better
matchup than against Carolina where I
think field position should ultimately
be very very good for New Orleans and
provide those plus opportunities for
tames yeah I mean no Michael Thomas no
Rasheed
Shahed Derek Carr's not playing well if
he plays it all I mean yeah it all sets
up for taes couple questions from chat
real quick here Diamond I Gunner says
Gino Smith or Russ Wilson I I think a
pretty cleanly better matchup
for uh Russ here but I don't think it's
like crazy to think Gino can have
another good game like he did against
Dallas this is a close one Leon what do
you think about Gino versus Russ at the
quarterback
spot yeah I think it's close I'd
ultimately side with the better matchup
for Russ because I think there's less
chance of like this huge valure from the
offense as a whole but it's pretty close
and you could definitely make the
argument that Gino has a better upside
case because just the quantity of pass
attempts we just haven't seen Russ
really sling a high volume of attempts
but he's been getting to like a decent
score week in and week out because of
efficiency Hernandez says Brandon Cooks
Z flowers or Garrett Wilson we just
talked about how much we like Brandon
Cooks but Z flowers is certainly a
pretty strong option as well here I love
Garrett Wilson Z Zack Wilson being
back I think it actually helps over Tim
Bole a little bit Zack Wilson being back
but man it's aough we go each week that
the new quarterback is better for
Garrett Wilson because we keep thinking
it can't get worse but it is tough I
they've at least let Zach throw the ball
more than I've kind of expected them to
but unless the weather in Baltimore is a
disaster I think I'm just taking the
better offense and better quarterback
play and siging was a flowers yeah yeah
keep an eye on the weather there on
flowers because I do think that is
reasonably close and if the weather is
not great I would probably go to Cooks
or Garrett Wilson all right finish up
our must starts to get to the fantasy
playoffs interesting one here in the
game before the buy the Bears shockingly
to me at least played Roshan Johnson
ahead of CLE Herbert well ahead I
believe rosan played 74% of the snaps in
that game and it wasn't because they
were it was a close game it seemed like
they wanted to go to Roshan now Deontay
foran were're expecting back this week
Herbert's not going away so this is
going to be a thinner sneakier
one but yeah I think Roshan is at least
worth considering for people that are in
binded at the running back position here
this week bears are home against the
Lions who have been giving up really
struggling on defense like reverting to
last year's defense have the
Lions you want to go ahead with our last
start of the
week yeah final start is going to be
courtand suon mentioned like in the
match up for Russ Wilson that of course
extends to sudden we've got both teams
with Team totals in the 20s which
doesn't sound great but uh it's pretty
rare this week with how gross some of
the totals are so it's one of the better
game environments completely isolated
from weather and su's role has just been
really consistent he's been the go-to
target for Russ he's been getting a good
quantity of targets he's been getting
downfield looks and his you know
propensity to find the end zone is huge
he's actually scored in every game but
three this year which is kind of wild to
score nine out of 12 games for an
offense that hasn't scored a whole ton
so will there be some regression there I
I think so but it's still a really good
spot for for su's efficiency I mean this
is what Russ does when he's playing well
right he's extremely efficient as a
touchdown thrower and that's kind of
what he's done this year all right and a
lot of it's a sudden recap our list here
must starts to make the playoffs Drake
London Zack Moss assuming Jonathan
Taylor is out again Romeo dobs assuming
Christian Watson is out Austin Eckler in
a nice bounceback spot get right here
for Austin Eckler Brandon Cooks in a
dream match up against the Eagles TM
Hill with all the saints injuries Roshan
Johnson ascending in that backfield and
courand Sutton the touchdown maker for
Russ
Wilson all right we got about five more
minutes here or so we'll get to as many
questions as we can Jordan says Evan
Ingram or Jake Ferguson man hashtag how
rich at the tight end position I think
these are actually two really strong
assets with Lawrence maybe out for this
game I think it's Jake Ferguson in this
matchup against the Eagles that said you
can make a case for Ingram if Lawrence
plays because with Christian Kirk out
there's a lot of targets to go around so
yeah any thoughts on that one
Leon I just love the cowbo boys passing
game this week so I think even if
Lawrence played I'd prefer you know a
potential shootout game there as opposed
to what could be more of a grinded out
game against a tough Cleveland defense
all right City Kitchen says Jerome Ford
or Naji Harris so nji is in this game
tonight he was like banged up with
something on a short week with the knee
and we know Jaylen Warren's really good
I don't think that I really am too
excited to play naagi tonight the
problem with four is that he's losing
too much work to creem hunt I still kind
of Lean Forward here though Leone but I
think it's pretty close what do you
think about Naji versus Ford I lean Ford
you know I think the targets for him
have been a little bit better than
they've been for Nagi but like nagi's
role has been pretty good I know people
were worried that it would just slide
more to Jaylen Warren with the
coordinator chains hasn't really
happened especially with Pittsburgh imp
positive game scripts uh at times s and
that's where they're expected to be
tonight in a run Fest so I think it's
really really close um i' probably go
with Ford if it's in full PPR if it's
more of like a standard League I think
Na's touchdown upside is a little bit
better and I'd go that route Romeo Jones
says should I flex Sam lorta or Devonte
Smith hashtag how rich for Romeo Jones I
mean I want to start both these guys
when it's close between tight end and
wide receiver I typically lean wide
receiver the outsized outcomes you get
from wide receiver the ceiling games are
so much higher than the typical ceiling
game from a tight end of course we just
saw leaport go for you know 25 points or
whatever he went for last week but I
still lean wide receiver here I think
Leoni leaport vers Devonte Smith yeah
Devonte Smith is the guy for me I just
think there's you know a few point gap
in projection for us there that I agree
with M Hernandez asks Isaiah likely or
Dallas Goddard Goddard sets a return
from his injury in quicker time than
maybe we expected and really like if
it's if it's close I'm going to this
Dallas Philly game I think goddard's the
better option anyways more talented
player more Reliant Target share I know
Phillies talked about establishing the
run a bit but you know even if they do
that it's pretty concentrated between
Gard Smith and AJ Brown I think there's
enough for gdd to get there yeah for
people who Maybe don't have as many
tight end riches as uh that last as M
Hernandez does Isaiah likely if he's on
your wire or whatever he's pretty solid
start man I mean he's going to run 70 80
85% of the routes out there and he's a
really athletic guy with Mark Andrews
out so I still like him Ian says DK mcaf
or Nico Collins my God how do you guys
have such good teams uh Nico Collins
gets a boost with tankel out like a big
boost with Tel out once tankel went out
last week Nico went nuts ended up
leading the the week in receiving yards
it would be hard for me to sit Nico
Collins really at any point here but man
sitting DK mcka doesn't feel great
either but I would go niik Collins any
thoughts there Leon you can go to the
next one
also I'll go Nico Collins it's not the
best spot but just too much upside with
tank D out whereas as good as MF was
last week the target Shares are still
somewhat even between three guys there
for Seattle Action Jackson asks Ravens
DST or Houston
DST uh I think Baltimore is in a great
spot they're an absurd defense they're
home bad weather against the Rams but
like I think I'm just taking the defense
against Zach Wilson especially I noted
before they're letting him throw a bit
more and that's good you know you want
the Jets to be throwing with a
quarterback who's not good at it and
who's going to take some sacks that old
lines had problems so I'll lean Houston
here on the matchup yeah Bree Hall is
banged up too I mean the easiest way to
pick your defense every week this whole
year has just been play whatever defense
is playing the Jets I mean you literally
have like the best defense if you just
switch your defense every week to
whoever is play jets are the Giants just
the New York teams pick on them kid play
nine last question we're going to do
here today says is Alexander Madison a
must start so I wouldn't call Alexander
Madison a must start I mean look at his
production this year despite having a
really good role all year that said
getting Jus Jefferson back really good
match up against the Raiders and the
Vikings haven't shown a big willingness
to give Tai Chandler an expanded role so
I doubt in a normal League you have a
better option than Alexander Madison
here against the Raiders but yeah I
would think about it by the way if
anyone ever needs to see what our
numbers say we always have our full week
projections you can see exactly how many
points we project for each player every
week over to establish the run all right
appreciate you all being here this was a
very fun week
14 Beach Report fan football show we
know everybody needs wins this week to
get into the playoffs SEC secure your
playoff positioning big big good
luck